hi this is feed a master mike klein
providing live press coverage of the
championship it's fascinating to see
what goes on behind the scenes to make
this coverage possible first of all we
are very grateful for the incredibly
thorough invent coordination by joy Bray
in our company she she the attention to
detail playing conditions the arbiters
and overall organization has been a real
treat the team of IT specialists are
some of our best unsung heroes they keep
everything running smoothly from the
network and servers to website
management and perhaps most importantly
the dgt boards my name is coastal from
the netherlands they flew me and just to
handle the dt port this facility is
world class so it's a lot of Planets
sure the most technologically advanced
chess club in the world also the
technology teams IP web cameras give us
a glimpse of the players in the
tournament this stream is broadcast
during mccauley Petersons live online
show which includes play-by-play
commentary and analysis by our
commentators woman's grandmaster
jennifer chehade and grandmaster maurice
ashley the coverage extends the reach of
the championships to thousands of online
viewers worldwide in 30 seconds they
team up with the production crew from
spectrum studios they produce the video
content throughout the event such as
interviews you roll 4 news outlets as
well as the recap videos which are shot
in a makeshift green screen studio
nearby garage last but not least the
post-production process keeps editor
Randy white working into the wee hours
of the morning to complete the video in
time for the afternoon broadcast welcome
to the first recap from the 2011 us
chess championships and US women's here
in st. Louis we'd like to extend a
heartfelt thank you to all the people
behind the scenes that make this
coverage possible